Hallo. Hallo und herzlich willkommen beim Chaosradio 291. Hallo und herzlich willkommen bei dem Podcast, der im Prinzip eine Tele-Novella ist. Also eigentlich passiert seit, also in meinem Gefühl, wir sprechen gleich noch genauer drüber, seit 20 Jahren dasselbe. Nämlich Menschen glauben Vorratsdaten, Speicherung, was das ist, erklären wir auch gleich nochmal kurz, sei eine gute Idee. Und dann kommen andere Menschen, die sagen nein. Und dann landet das vor Gericht und das Gericht sagt auch nein. Und wenn euch das alles bekannt vorkommt, haben wir heute eine frohe Nachricht für euch. Heute wird alles anderes. Ein Gericht hat ja gesagt, ja zur Vorratsdaten-Speicherung. Herzlich willkommen zum Chaosradio. Den muss man dich noch vorstellen? Konz ist mal wieder hier, herzlich willkommen. Nibler ist auch mal wieder da.
Mahlzeit.
Man kennt Nibler vom Club und vom Chaosradio, obwohl das auch schon ein bisschen länger her ist. Und du machst Dinge mit Telekommunikation. Das ist nicht zu viel versprochen, oder? Du weißt, wie Dinge passieren, also wie das tatsächlich mit dem Internet aus der Wand fällt, passiert und noch mehr. Und Mobilfunk, glaube ich, auch.
Genau, das ist standardisiert.
Kurz zur Verständnisfrage, ist das so, ich kaufe ein Produkt, hänge das bei mir rein und dann kontrolliere aber ich als Telekommunikationsanbieter das Produkt oder sind die dann noch als dritter?
Das ist sogar so, dass du als Telekommunikationsanbieter, du brauchst das ja auch für Lofoten Interception, also für Abhörschnittstellen, weil da ist ja auch die...
Das hört sich an wie ein Trojaner, den ich mit einbaue.
Ja, aber einer, der zertifiziert ist.
Na, der hängt schon, das sind schon Geräte in den internen Netzwerkstrukturen natürlich, aber die sind auch vorgeschrieben. Du kannst ja als deutscher großer Provider natürlich nicht sagen...
Aber nochmal, wer administriert dieses Gerät? Tut das natürlich der Kommunikationsanbieter selber oder tut das die Firma, die das Gerät zur Verfügung stellt?
Das tut in der Regel die Firma, die das Gerät zur Verfügung stellt. Die beauftragst du damit, dass sie das Gerät dahinstellt. Die beauftragst du damit, dass sie das Gerät anpasst oder die Geräte anpasst. Und mit denen und deinen Technikern im Haus guckt man dann, dass man das eben integriert. Und das ist so weit, dass bei Abhörmaßnahmen du als Netzbetreiber gar nicht erkennen können darfst. Erkennen können darfst. Also es muss dir unmöglich sein zu erkennen, welcher deiner Anschlüsse zu welcher Zeit von welchen Bedarfsträgern abgehört wird.
Wow. Also manche Bedarfsträger, namentliche Geheimdienste zum Beispiel, die dürfen nicht bekannt sein gegenüber demjenigen, der die Kommunikationsdienstleistung erbringt.
Die Firma, die das gerät, die weiß das schon. Also ich will nur so sagen, auf der aktivistischen Ebene heißt das, es gibt hier einen Datenberg, der grundrechtsrelevant ist und die nicht nur der Telekommunikationsdienst, der ist ja meistens eh weiß, weil er das braucht. Und auch nicht die Behörden, die Strafverfolgung, sondern auch noch eine dritte Partei, die die Technik zur Verfügung stellt.
Ich glaube, wir dürfen jetzt aber auch nicht generalisieren, dass das immer überall so ist. Also, mir sind auch Fälle bekannt, dass durchaus Strafverfolgungsbehörden zu irgendwo hingehen und sagen, hey, dieser Anschluss hier, da brauchen wir, das leite uns das mal aus. Ich glaube, es kommt auch ein bisschen auf die Größe des Unternehmens an, oder?
Durchaus, ja. Aber da, wo das eben automatisiert ist, also ich kenne es aus den Anforderungsdokumenten, ist eben immer darauf geachtet, dass wenn das automatisiert passiert, dann ist der Personenkreis, der auf die Liste der aktiven Maßnahmen Zugriff hat, möglichst klein. Idealerweise 0 kann man natürlich nicht, aber eben möglichst klein zu halten.
Das stimmt, aber in so einem Unternehmen wissen es wirklich sehr, sehr wenig Leute, wer gerade überwacht wird.
Und wie teuer ist das? Nein, nein, ich stelle mich zum Missverständnis. Ich wollte keine Hausnummer haben, sondern im Sinne von, wenn ich Telekommunikationsdienstleister bin, betreibe ich Infrastruktur. Infrastruktur kostet Geld. Das Ding kostet auch Geld. Ich will eher sozusagen so ein Verhältnis. Also habe ich dann 100%? Also verdoppelt sich mein Aufwand? Oder ist es eher sozusagen so ein Peanuts? Oder ist es eher 10%? Also im Sinne von, man muss schon Geld ausgeben, aber ist es schon auch verschmerzbar?
Na, ich würde schon eher sagen, das ist verschmerzbar, wenn man das nur in Geld betrachtet. Aufwand ist aber ein bisschen mehr als nur Geld.
Na ja, und das ist verschmerzbar. Also für einen Telekommunikationsanbieter ist das schon kein Ding, was sie gerne machen wollen. Von dem Geld könnten sie andere Infrastruktur oder günstigere Tarife oder was auch immer. Also für den Telco- oder Internetanbieter. Gerade bei den geringen Margen, die es da teilweise hat, ist das schon, ja, gerne machen die das nicht.
Also man kann sagen, es ist leistbar, aber es fällt durchaus auch schon ins Gewicht.
Es war anfangs mal eine riesige Debatte. Das liegt ja auch daran, also die muss ich jetzt schon klar machen. In Deutschland haben sich die großen Internet-Dienstleister ja auch, vor allen Dingen auch der Verband Echo, stark gemacht dafür. Die haben die Gerichtsurteile mit erkämpft. In dem SpaceNet-Fall etwa, der zum EuGH ging und der erfolgreich war, hat sich auch der Verband hintergestellt. Also die sind jetzt keine Befürworter. Am Anfang war das auch mal eine Diskussion, ob das überhaupt bei den Providern gespeichert wurde, warum das selbstverständlich sein sollte, dass die das bezahlen und so.
Und auch die Frage, ob die Strafverfolgungsbehörden und Interessensträger denn vielleicht pro Maßnahme auch bezahlen durften, dass das erkämpft und da steht.
Also das ist schon auch eine lange Debatte. Ich würde auch nicht sagen, dass es keine Nicht-Debatte ist, aber ich glaube in unserem Kontext, wo der doch immer eher um diese gerichtliche Entscheidung geht und Verhältnismäßigkeit ist, ist es dann doch eher nicht so eine Priorität in der Diskussion, würde ich sagen. Technisch, du brauchst ja auch Leute und so. Das ist ja nicht nur das Equipment. Du musst das auch zu 24-7 zur Verfügung stellen. Das hängt auf Wochenendearbeit dran.
Bündig ist das auch nicht.
Ich glaube, dass was Constanze sagt, ist nochmal ganz wichtig, dass man das auch als Hörer und Hörerin zusammenbekommt. Bei Vorratsdatenspeicherung geht es immer so darum, dass der Staat sagt, du musst das tun. Du hast keine andere Wahl, weil wir verpflichten dich dazu. Was natürlich immer wichtiger geworden ist, auch durch den Wandel der Kommunikation in den letzten Jahren, was Constanze gesagt hat, ist, dass Strafverfolgungsbehörden natürlich zudem auch anfragen bei Unternehmen, die gar nicht verpflichtet sind, aber die trotzdem Daten haben. Du hast eben das Beispiel, E-Mails werden auseinandergetauscht. Die alle nutzen WhatsApp und so weiter. Auch bei WhatsApp kann natürlich eine Strafverfolgungsbehörde fragen, sag mal über diese Telefonnummer, mit wem hat dir denn eigentlich irgendwelche Nachrichten und so weiter hin und her geschrieben. Das sind auch Vorratsdaten in dem Sinne, technisch genau gleich. Die sind auch gespeichert, nur sozusagen, sie sind aus kommerziellen Gründen einfach da und werden natürlich abgefragt. Das ist jetzt nicht Teil dieser Debatte, aber wird natürlich in der Strafverfolgungspraxis auch sehr, sehr rege gemacht mit zunehmendem Eifer.
Und was da an Daten gespeichert werden, also das muss man sich mal klar sein, bei WhatsApp tauscht man sein Telefonbuch gegen das Privileg, diesen Dienstbücher zu nutzen. denen liegt dein komplettes Telefonbuch vor in Klartext.
Ich glaube, wir gerade schon eine Runde beim Satz, wir alle nutzen WhatsApp.
Die eigentlich Bekenntenden nicht benutzen.
Das ist nicht ganz richtig, aber es ist natürlich mega weit.
Statistisch stimmt es.
Das Schlimme ist, ich benutze das nicht, weil ich den Deal, mein Telefonbuch gegen die Kommunikationsdienstleistung einzutauschen, wo ich noch nicht meine Telefonnummer für ergeben muss, weil es gibt Streamer. Aber selbst wenn ich das nicht nutze, ich kenne ja sehr viele Menschen, die meine Telefonnummer in ihrem Telefonbuch haben. Sie haben umgekehrt quasi ein rückwärts Telefonbuch. Wer kennt alles diesen Nippler und seine Telefonnummer?
Ich jetzt sozusagen letzte Frage nochmal zu diesem technischen Ding und auch zum Budget, damit wir dann wieder zu den Speicherfristen zurückkommen, ist, es ist also finanzieller Aufwand, der ist leistbar, fällt aber durchaus ins Gewicht. Wie viel schlimmer wird das, wenn man es länger speichert? Also ist zum Beispiel, wenn ich statt sechs Monate in den Jahr speicher, ist das eine Verdopplung der Kosten? Oder ist das dann so Festplatz kostet nichts, das ist dann auch egal?
Das ist ja auch eine Funktion des Volumens, was man an Daten durch sein Netz schiebt. Und allein auf der Basis haben wir in den letzten Jahren eine Verringerung der gespeicherten Daten gesehen. Also der Daten, die Netzbetreiber für Analysezwecke speichern, um eben auch Missbrauch im Netz, also im Sinne von technischer Missbrauch an Kommunikationseinrichtungen. Weil eben das Volumen auch immer mehr wird an Daten, die da anfallen.
Aber du hast die Frage nicht beantwortet. Also wird der finanziell wirtschaftliche Auswand relevant höher, wenn ich die Speicherung der Metadaten verlängere? Oder ist es, wenn es eh schon mal eingerichtet ist, dann ist sozusagen mehr an Daten nicht so sehr ins Gewicht. Also ums platt zu sagen, wenn ich mir einen Computer kaufe, dann gebe ich da im Zweifel irgendwie so was zwischen 1000 und 1500 Euro aus, wenn er halbwegs aktuell ist. Wenn der noch mal eine doppelt so große Festplatte braucht, fällt jetzt nicht mehr so richtig doll ins Gewicht. Das ist die Frage, die ich quasi stelle. Also ist das Einrichten das Teure und der Speicherplatz dann eher egal oder ist längere Speicherrefrist noch mal relevanter zusätzlicher Aufwand?
Naja, zunächst das sehr teure Computer, die man da einsetzt. Also einer der Marktführer, Verbauchter meines Wissens, Oracle Server. Da kann sich jeder selber ausrechnen, welche Preisklasse das ist und wie teuer dann entsprechend auch...
Niemand außer dir kann sich ausrechnen, was eine Oracle Server kostet. Sag kurz eine Hausnummer, wenn du schon dabei bist.
Wenn du fragen musst, dann ist es zu teuer.
Das ist schon...
Wir reden über fünfstellig? Für einen? Nein, das ist nur...
Also eine hohe fünfstellige Summe.
Also das ist die Anschaffung und dann?
Nein, wie gesagt, ich kann dir das keine Zwei nennen, aber mehr ist halt mehr und es wird immer mehr, dadurch, dass mehr Last auf den Netzen ist.
Also ich finde, er hat die Frage insofern beantwortet, dass die Telekommunikationsanbieter natürlich ein Interesse hatten, dieses Volumen zu reduzieren. Einfach bald immer teurer wird. Denn wir reden in den 20 Jahren über ungefähr 80-Fachung des Volumens. Das ist ja enorm, was die Leute produzieren. Die haben natürlich Interesse davon, klar. Und du musst das auch immer zusätzlich sichern. Bei längeren Zeiträumen kannst du das nämlich nicht mehr so, du kannst das nicht für so einen kurzen Zeitraum irgendwo lassen, sondern du musst dir dann ein echtes Konzept machen für eine längere Speicherung, wohin, unter IT-Sicherheitsbedingungen, die du zu gewährleisten hast. Das ist ja unheimlich mal so ein Kostenfaktor. Also das ist schon unangenehm.
Das sind ja auch nicht irgendwelche Daten, sondern das sind Daten, auf die man möglichst aufpassen muss.
Ja, wir haben ja noch gar nicht über die Speicherfristen im Urteil gesprochen. Da hab ich natürlich, wie ihr euch das vorstellen könnt, das war das erste, wonach ich suchte. Und tatsächlich haben sie nichts dazu drin. Sie sagen, man muss es auf das absolut Notwendige beschränken. Das ist so ein Terminus, den die jetzt oft drin haben, der ist schon seit 2020 etabliert.
Das heißt, da kann man sich dann fantastisch wieder vor Gerichte überstreiten, was das bedeutet?
Ja, das ist tatsächlich, also da steht keine Woche oder Monate oder sonst irgendwas drin, sondern nur das absolut Notwendige. Das ist wie so eine Art Phrase mittlerweile. Und das war natürlich auch so ein Teil der Kritik.
Das war doch, glaub ich, das wirst du besser wissen, aber ich glaube, bei dem 2010er-Urteil des Verfassungsgerichtes war es doch auch so. Sie haben gesagt, sechs Monate ist zu lang. Aber was, also, aber sie haben jetzt auch nicht gesagt, aber drei gingen oder so, ne?
Aber das ist ja auch, da hatten sie einen konkreten gesetzter Stand, ja? Und hier ist es ja nicht ganz so. Also man muss, man finde, man sollte doch nicht so den Gerichten überhelfen, ja? Letztlich, also die fühlende Debatte darüber in Deutschland.
Der Gesetzgeber sollte Gesetz geben, meinst du nicht, das Gericht?
Naja, okay, dann sind wir jetzt noch auf einer anderen Ebene. Das ist die erste Plenumsentscheidung des EuGH. Ein Plenum bedeutet, dass die, die große Kammer, die haben verschiedene große Kammern bei diesem Gericht, dass die sich nicht einig wurde. Also sie haben das Plenum von allen 27 EuGH-Richtern für diese Urteile herangezogen. Das ist ein Novum.
Ich muss gleich so eine Detailfrage stellen, weil ich habe jetzt in dem, ich habe schon die öffentliche Wahrnehmung so wahrgenommen wiederum, dass das schon was Neues ist, was da passiert ist. Und dann wurde auch immer darüber spekuliert, wie ist das zustande gekommen? Und dann gibt es natürlich so, naja, also im Prinzip, wenn man sich das anguckt, dann kann man über die Jahre schon feststellen, dass das abzusehen war, dass das irgendwie so sagen die einen und die anderen sagen so, naja, das hängt schon auch damit zusammen, wer beim EuGH da gerade Berichterstatter ist, glaube ich, dass das das richtige Wort ist. Gab es da sozusagen, genau, gibt es da so eine Art Personalwechsel? Also woran lag es, dass die jetzt quasi umgeschwenkt sind?
Dazu muss man sich, glaube ich, eins klarmachen. Und eine ist, deutschlandweit haben wir eine Debatte über die Forensikansprechung. Anderswo ist das überhaupt nicht der Fall. Wir haben eine ganz große Mehrheit in Europa, die ja auch beim EuGH abgebildet wird über die Rechte, die überhaupt nicht streitet über die Forensikansprechung. Das ist echt ein Unterschied. Dann, also ich denke, steht der Tropfen höht den Stein. Die nationalen Regierungen in Europa haben weitgehend ignorant gegenüber den EuGH-Urteilen agiert. In Deutschland ist das was anderes. Aber die trommeln unablässig, obwohl es diese vielen Urteile gab. Ich hab die vorhin genannt. 14, 16, 20 und jetzt wieder. Die trommeln wie die Blöden. Wir haben bei Netzpolitik zum Beispiel einen Diplomatenbericht öffentlich machen können, der die Haltung der verschiedenen EU-Staaten zur Vorwahrzeithesprechung darstellt. Und die wollen das alle. Wir sind eine der wenigen Ländern, wo das anders ist. Und da muss man schon sagen, da halten die vielleicht auch nicht immer stand. Aber trotzdem haben sie letztlich diese Tür nur ein sehr, sehr kleines Stück geöffnet. Also für mich ist das Trommeln trotzdem nicht erfolgreich gewesen.
Ich bin immer noch, der Einschätzung ist unklar. Du sagst, sie haben die Tür nur ein kleines Stückchen mehr geöffnet. Aber die Tür ist jetzt offen und vorher war sie zu?
Nein, auch schon nein. Sie haben die Vorwahrzeithesprechung im Prinzip ja erlaubt für schwere Kriminalität, wenn sie auf das absolut Notwendige beschränkt ist, auch schon in einem früheren Urteil, was die IP-Adressen angeht.
Ich glaube halt, die Frage ist immer so ein bisschen, wollen wir das jetzt juristisch bewerten? Oder wollen wir überlegen, was heißt das für den politischen Diskurs? Für den politischen Diskurs ist das, glaube ich, schon eines der wichtigsten Urteile der letzten Jahre. Weil es eben nicht nur im Kern konstanze darum geht, was steht da juristisch für juristische Feinheiten drin, sondern wie wird es genutzt als Argument in der politischen Diskussion? Und schon das letzte EuGH-Urteil, wo es um schwere Kriminalität ging, war für die Befürworter derjenigen in Deutschland, die das wollen, die Vorratsanspeicherung wollen, das ganz klare Argument, um die Ampel vor sich hertreiben zu können und einfach sagen zu können, der EuGH hat gesagt, es geht. Und auch da steht eigentlich drin, dass es nur unter sehr bestimmten Bedingungen geht. Aber es wurde dann sozusagen kommunikativ so verpackt, hey, der EuGH sagt, es geht, ihr macht es nicht. Ihr lasst also sozusagen willend nicht zu, dass Kriminalität nicht aufgeklärt werden kann. Und das ist schon, ich glaube nicht, dass das mit dem Urteil besser wird. Ich glaube, das wird eher mehr.
Also du kannst es auch noch ein drittes Mal sagen, was du vorhin im Prinzip schon gesagt hast. Und Markus hat jetzt auch gesagt, ich teile das nicht. Natürlich gibt es vor dem Befürworter hier ein Interesse zu sagen, diese Urteile machen einen Unterschied. Aber in der Sache ist es gerade kein Dammbruch. Ich finde diese Framing falsch und wurde jetzt hier gemacht, unmittelbar nach dem Urteil. Ich bin mir aber auch ziemlich sicher bei den vielen Juristen, die sich damit beschäftigen, die sich jetzt darüber beugen werden, die ja teilweise auch schon gemacht haben, dass die Einschätzung ein bisschen anders sein wird. Das ändert aber nichts an den politischen Forderungen. Das stimmt schon. Aber dann ist der Dammbruch eigentlich schon vorher gewesen, nämlich zu sagen, ein bisschen anlasslos geht. Aber nicht an diesem Urteil jetzt vom 30.
Das möchte ich noch einmal so sagen. Ich möchte es noch einmal nachfragen im Sinne von, ich verstehe das einerseits, dass der Dammbruch schon früher war, wenn man sagt, Vorratssatenspeicherung gibt es so. Dann ist der Drops gelutscht, könnte man sagen. Weil dann geht es nur noch um die Anwendung. Was macht man dann damit? Deswegen verstehe ich deine Einschätzung nicht ganz. Ich kann sie juristisch nachvollziehen, dass man sich hinschaut und sagt, das Urteil, dass es so eng fokussiert, da lässt sich nichts draus ableiten. Ich hätte gedacht, selbst wenn man diese Einschätzung teilt, würde ich denken, es gibt aber das Signal. Wenn du dich nur genug anstrengst, in der Art und Weise, wie du deine Gesetze formulierst, dann kannst du es halt für alles verwenden, wenn selbst Falschhering geht. Das wäre meine Angst jetzt. Aber das siehst du nicht.
Das würde ich schon auch so sehen, wenn ich jetzt auf diese Trommelfeuer über die Jahre und die vielen nationalen Gesetze und so, die ja auch zwischendrin sehr beschlossen wurden. Aber für diesen konkreten Fall stimmt es halt auch schlicht nicht, weil das so ein uraltes Gesetz ist. Das ist halt ein 2010er Dekret. Trotzdem hat natürlich diese politische Trommel eine Wirkung. Und da sitzen halt auch Vertreter von Europa, die andere Haltung haben, als sie hier üblicherweise sozusagen im öffentlichen Diskurs sind. Aber dennoch sozusagen die grundsätzliche Haltung ist anlassloses, verdachtsloses, massenspeichert, europarechtskonform? Da ist die Antwort immer noch nein. Es gibt ein paar Ausnahmen, ja, das steht auch in diesem Urteil so drin. Du kannst sozusagen nicht einfach massenhaft bevölkerungsweit sprechen, aber sie machen halt gewisse Einschränkungen. Sie sagen, unter diesen und jenen Umständen, wenn zum Beispiel keine Rückschlüsse auf das private Leben möglich sind, also keine Profilierung, kannst du das aufs absolut Notwendige beschränkt tun. Das ist doch ein Unterschied.
Also sozusagen, woran ich scheitere, ist sozusagen der für mich, in meinem Gehirn, Entschuldigung, noch nicht aufgelöste Widerspruch, dass man anscheinend da auslesen kann, dass es im Grundsatz nicht okay ist, aber es passiert da trotzdem mit. Wie das zusammenpasst, das verstehe ich.
Die Einschränkung ist, wenn du in diesem Datenpol nur für einen sehr, sehr, sehr kleinen Grund automatisiert reinschaust, dann kannst du diesen Datenpol anlegen.
Und wenn du dabei ausschließen kannst, dass es auch diese Privatleben, Einblicke in den Privatleben der Betroffenen gibt.
Genau, aber du hast ja die ganze Zeit die Formulierung benutzt sozusagen. Es ist grundsätzlich nicht erlaubt, diese Datenspeicherung anzulegen, aber die passiert ja.
Vielleicht verstehst du auch dieses Wort grundsätzlich anders. Man meint die Juristen, es ist nicht okay. Und dann kommt so ein Aber und sie haben im konkreten Fall dann diese oder jene Regelung, die dem doch erlauben. Das ist nicht grundsätzlich in der Sinne von nein, nein, nein, nein, das darfst du nicht, sondern das ist erstmal nicht okay. Aber für diese oder jene spezielle Regelung kann man das auf das absolut notwendige Bestehen tun. Also vielleicht hängst du dazu sehr an der Alltagssprache und bist nicht sozusagen diese juristische...
Das ist korrekt, dafür bin ich ja hier.
Ich bin auch kein Jurist, wir haben schon so oft diese Urteile gelesen.
Okay, wir müssen jetzt noch zwei Dinge klären. Das eine ist, und das klang ja schon an, aber ich hätte gerne, dass es noch mal expliziert, was wird das für politische Folgen in Deutschland haben? Also wird jetzt jemand ankommen und sagen, auch wenn es vielleicht juristisch keinen Sinn macht, lass mal vor zur Ansprechung machen. Und danach sprechen wir über die Alternativen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob für heute noch solche Alternativen kommen. Ich glaube nur, dass alle dann jetzt die Linie fahren werden. Es hat sich auch sehr festgesetzt. Der Urteil ist so kommentiert worden. Alle werden sagen, hier, geht doch jetzt irgendwie.
Man könnte es so formulieren, selbst als klare Absagen gab von den Gerichten, das geht nicht. Und sozusagen die Kommentierung war, ist ausgeschlossen. Gab es trotzdem eine Fraktion, die gesagt hat, brauchen wir aber trotzdem. Und diese Fraktion wird ja jetzt nicht sagen, wo die Tür ein bisschen aufgeht, ah, jetzt wollen wir nicht mehr. Sondern das wird natürlich eher benutzt, um zu sagen, naja, im Prinzip das, was wir jetzt schon haben, die Gerichte erlauben es, liebe Bundesregierung, warum macht ihr es nicht, ihr jeden Tag passieren Straftaten und ihr könntet es eigentlich abstellen. Das ist sozusagen der politische Druck, der gerade aus der Opposition aufgebaut wird.
Darf ich noch mal Quick Freeze sagen?
Ja, da kommen wir ja gleich zu.
Vielleicht passt es jetzt aber gerade, sonst kann man ja nicht über die Einigung reden, die gerade besteht.
Ich wollte noch kurz gefragt haben, von den großen Parteien, die im Bundestag sitzen, von den größeren demokratischen Parteien, die im Bundesrat sitzen, kann man das klar verorten für Gegenvorratsdatenspeicherung?
Das Bundeskasten weiß Brot möchte Quick Freeze.
Nein, ich glaube, man kann nicht...
Leute, jetzt mach ich das. Was sagt die CDU dazu?
Die Union? Ich glaube, man kann jetzt nicht immer bei jeder Partei für je... Vielleicht gibt es immer mal eine Person, die da irgendwie sagt, ich würde es anders sehen, aber im Wesentlichen kann man sagen, die Linke, die Grünen und die FDP sind eher bis klar gegen die Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Bei der Union kann man sagen, die sind eher bis klar dafür. Und bei der SPD kommt es schon relativ stark an, zu welchem Politikfeld arbeiten die Leute. Also die Innenpolitiker der SPD sind eher dafür. Dann gibt es aber auch wirklich viele bei der SPD, die sagen, das geht mit uns so nicht. Genau, und deswegen ist gerade, einfach weil wir im Moment eben Grün und FDP in der Bundesregierung haben, war da relativ klar, steht ja auch im Koalitionsvertrag, so eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung wird es nicht geben, sondern eben Quick Freeze. Aber meine persönliche Meinung ist schon, dass sollte die Union in die Bundesregierung kommen mit einer SPD. Also wenn es wieder eine GroKo gäbe, dann kann ich mir schon sehr gut vorstellen, dass eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung wieder eingeführt würde.
Also Menschen mit Vorbehalten gegenüber Grundrechtseinschränkungen in der SPD, die haben die grundsätzlich schon immer mit argem Bauchweh, aber dann doch mit Ertragungen.
Heiko Maas hat sie damals eingeführt, der SPD-Justizminister.
Sie haben es schon unterschrieben. Daniel hat erwähnt, Sie haben es unterschrieben im Koalitionsvertrag. Keine anlasslosen Maßensprechungen.
Kommt ja auch wieder zu Wahlen.
Spannend wird es sein, wenn wir sowas wie Schwarz-Grün bekämen. Schon interessant, Schaffen es die Grünen, sich dazu zu widersetzen.
Aber es gibt Alternativen. Verbrecher fangen im Internet mit Quick Freeze! Das klingt wie so ein geiles Produkt.
Was ist das?
Der Punkt, den ich aufmachen wollte, ist, dass es bei der Speicherfrist ein Continuum gibt. Auf der einen Seite des Continuums, wie gesagt, Quick Freeze, dass es die kürzest vorstellbare Speicherdauer ist. Nämlich so lange, wie das eh beim Provider anfällt. Das finde ich eine spannende Diskussion. Eigentlich fallen diese Daten zwar an, aber es gibt immer weniger Gründe, diese Daten aufzuheben. Deswegen bin ich mir nicht sicher, inwieweit der diskutierte Quick Freeze... Warte mal, stopp.
Du kannst jetzt nicht sagen, wenn ich frage, was ist Quick Freeze, mit der Kritik an Quick Freeze anfangen, sondern was ist den Quick Freeze?
Das war nicht die Kritik an Quick Freeze, die kommt noch. Quick Freeze ist das Einfrieren der vorhandenen Daten. Also das wird die technisch wegspeichern. Vorhin hat Nebla ein paar Details gesagt, dass die eingefroren werden ab dem Zeitpunkt, wo ein Strafverfolger sagt, die hätten wir gerne. Dann muss noch mal ein Richter drüber gucken. Wenn der sagt, das ist ein ernsthafter Verdacht, dann werden die übergeben.
Ab dem Zeitpunkt in die Zukunft kann man auch sagen, man möchte jetzt Daten speichern aus dem und dem Grund.
Das ist heute schon möglich. Wenn ich das als Alternative zur Vorratsansprechung höre, hört das für mich an, es gibt in Deutschland eine Schalter. Wenn jemand sagt, QuickFreeze, dann lebt der Schalter umgelegt, dann wird überall Daten gespeichert. Ich hätte jetzt für sinnvoller gehalten, wenn man sagt QuickFreeze, man hat schon den Verdacht, es betrifft dann einen Anschluss oder einen Anbieter oder einen Aha.
Das ist natürlich nicht für die gesamte Bevölkerung, es ist wirklich so, stell dir vor, es gibt eine Beleidigung im Netz, die vielleicht eine schwere Straftat erfüllen würde, warum auch immer, dann weißt du aber nicht, wer steckt eigentlich in diesem Facebook-Account, dann kann es sein, dass du als Strafverfolgungsbehörde im Moment das Problem hast, weil manche Abläufe noch relativ lang sind, dass du in diesen zwei, drei Tagen, was wenig klingt, aber das genau die Zeit ist, wo vielleicht Daten aus technischen Gründen beim Netzbetreiber gelöscht würden, dann kannst du eben diesen Button drücken, verbild dich gesagt, sagen, wir haben da vielleicht was, wir möchten uns das im Zweifel angucken und sozusagen die Formalien erreichen.
Aber das heißt, ich müsste schon sozusagen eine IP-Adresse wissen?
Genau, ja, also zumindest brauchst du, du musst irgendwas haben, wo du auf jemanden zugehst und sagst, wir müssen zu diesem, wir wissen nicht genau, wer dahinter steckt, das ist ja immer bei Vorratsdatenspeicher. Und das wollte ich eben schon einmal gesagt haben. Es geht nicht so sehr darum, wir sehen ja die Konstanz, sondern wir wollen wissen, was die so alles tut, sondern der Standardfall bei Vorratsdatenspeichern ist eher, wir wissen nicht, wer dahinter steckt und sag du uns bitte, wer steckt hinter diesen technischen Daten. Das ist eigentlich der Anwendungsfall.
Genau, aber das heißt sozusagen, für QuickFree brauche ich ein Telekommunikationsdatum. Also weil du gerade gesagt hast, Facebook-Account.
Du brauchst grundsätzlich kein Problem, um mit der VDS irgendwas anzufangen, Kommunikationsdatum. Das ist die Übersetzung von einem Kommunikationsdatum in eine Person.
Der Klassiker wäre dann, du fragst bei Facebook, mit welcher IP-Adresse wurde sich da eingeloggt? Dann kriegst du die IP-Adresse und dann musst du ja wiederum zum Netzbetreiber rennen und sagen, wer nutzt die Dekadatum?
Genau, das war mir wichtig, gerade noch klarzustellen, weil du musst...
Aber ein bisschen genauer müssen wir schon sein. Alle Beispiele sind jetzt... Es liegt einen Gesetzentwurf dafür vor. Der ist zwar schon ein bisschen älter, der ist von 2022. Und der soll es jetzt auch neuen geben. Und da werden sie vielleicht ein paar andere Sachen machen. Aber das bezieht sich jetzt nicht unbedingt nur auf so ein einspezifisches Ding. Es kann schon auch einen größeren Rahmen Einfrähung geben.
Was heißt größeren Rahmen?
Naja, man könnte auch sagen, ich brauch zum Beispiel mal die Daten von bestimmten Funkzellen oder so. Also das muss jetzt nicht so klein sein. Es gibt auch Kritik an dem Quick-Freeze-Verfahren aus bürgerrechtlicher Sicht.
Stopp, stopp, stopp, den Scope erst mal erklären. Also die Ausweitung. Entweder hast du ein konkretes Telekommunikationsdatum oder du kannst es weiterfassen. Das Weiterfassen ist zum Beispiel eine Funkzelle. Ist das auch ein kompletter Telekommunikationsanbieter oder ein Stadtteil oder wie muss man sich das vorstellen?
Je nachdem, was du für eine Straftat verfolgen wirst und wozu sagen dein Ansatz ist. Du kannst erst mal sagen, ich will auch mehr Daten einfrieren. Und daran macht sich jetzt die Kritik fest.
Aber es ist sozusagen beschränkt auf Telekommunikationsanbieter. Also sie sagen nicht, also man könnte ja auch sowas machen, wie das mal bei sozialen Netzwerken sagt, du musst eine gewisse Weile vorhalten, welche IP-Adressen sich auf den Account connectet haben oder so. Aber es geht nur um die, die wirklich die technische Infrastruktur und die technische Telekommunikation.
Das war es im Wesentlichen schon. Es gibt Verbände von Berufsgeheimnisträgern, die natürlich da sagen, im Detail müsste man da schon noch mal draufschauen, weil wir bestimmte Berufsgruppen haben, die klassische Berufsgeheimnisträger sind. Und da müsste man vielleicht ein paar Ausnahmen machen, bei der Einbringerei, weil dann meine Mandanten, wenn ich ein Anwalt bin oder meine Quellen als Journalist in einer besonderen Gefährdung ausgesetzt sind. Also ein zweistubiges Verfahren zum Beispiel. Also wer prüft, ob dieses Einfrieren auch okay war?
Aber das heißt ja eigentlich, wenn diese Kritik stattgegeben werden würde, würde das ja wiederum bedeuten, du kannst dann das nicht mehr machen, dass du eine Funkzelle einfrierst, weil dann hast du ja im Zweifel diese Leute dabei.
Wie gesagt, das ist eher so ein rechtliche Ding. Wer guckt da drauf und prüft, ob es okay ist? Also es geht erstmal um die Schnelligkeit. Wir haben das noch nicht erwähnt. Also die ganze Vorarztdaten-Speicherung-Debatte geht auch immer darum, dass diese Daten flüchtig sind in diesem Sinne von Strafverfolgern. Leute müssen schnell handeln, um Daten, die irgendwo beim Telekommunikationsanbieter vorliegen, einfrieren, festhalten, haben zu können. Und QuickFree soll genau das leisten. Erstmal schnell einfrieren, aber wichtig ist natürlich für das Gesetz, wie ist es ausgestellt danach? Wer entscheidet, ob die wirklich in großen Mengen dann auch weitergegeben werden?
Frage. Diese Kritik, bestimmte Berufsgruppen sollen da ausgeschlossen werden. Bezieht sich das darauf, dass deren Daten gar nicht erst gespeichert werden dürfen? Oder bezieht sich das darauf, dass, wenn die, keine Ahnung, aus Versehen oder im Treibnetz irgendwie mit, also Mobilfunkzelle, irgendwie wurde komplett QuickFreezed und sagt die Kritik dann, ihr müsst erst mal gucken. Und wenn dann Geheimnis regeln, dann müssen die rausgenommen werden. Dann dürft ihr die Daten erst benutzen.
Das ist die ganz große Kritik. Das, wo ich sage, wenn wir anlasslose Massenüberwachung wollen, dann müssen wir uns eingestehen, dass es niemals ein perfektes Verfahren gibt, um bestimmte Individuen, die wir eigentlich schützen und rausnehmen wollen, da rechtssicher rausfiltern können. Denn entweder wir haben diesen Ansatz erst mal alles und dann ist es ja nur möglich, bestimmte Leute rauszufiltern. Wenn ich die irgendwie entweder kennzeichne bei der Erfassung, das ist dein Punkt so, ja, ganz ehrlich, das will ich nicht. Also ich will jetzt nicht, dass irgendwie an meiner Handy noch mein digitales Wimpel hängt, der ist übrigens Journalist und rede mit interessanten Leuten. Auf gar keinen Fall. Das heißt, es wird dann eher klassischerweise darauf kommen, na ja, wenn man die Daten abfragt und man erkennt dann, oh, das sind hier irgendwie schützenswerte Personen, dann dürfen wir die vielleicht doch nicht herausgreifen. Das klingt juristisch immer ganz toll. In der Praxis ist das, sorry, totaler Bullshit. Also da guckt jemand drauf und die haben doch mit der Materie nichts zu tun. Du kannst doch jetzt nicht von Leuten bei einem Netzbetreiber verlangen, dass die noch eine juristische Prüfung machen. Ist der Journalist? Ist der irgendwas? Und das rechtssicher und so weiter. Das glaube ich einfach nicht. Also dem will ich einfach nicht vertrauen. Also natürlich könnten wir das aufhalten, aber das ist einfach etwas, wo ich sage...
Das ist nicht zu leisten.
Das ist nichts, wo ich als Journalist dann sage, ach so, wenn es so ist, dann ist es doch nicht so schlimm. Dann vertraue ich doch wieder auf den Quellenschutz. Das mag man dann alles so tun. Aber das ist nichts, wo ich von meiner grundsätzlichen Kritik dann für meine Berufsgruppe abweiche. Das mag dann vielleicht den Schaden etwas begrenzen in dem, was man geht. Aber indem man sich entschieden hat, wir machen diese analysierte Massenüberwachung, müssen wir uns klar sein, dass dort immer Kollateralschäden rausputzeln werden, die wir nicht komplett wegfiltern können.
Naja, man muss eines hinzufügen. Selbstverständlich, und das müssen auch, das gelten das Recht, Provider, die Anforderungen kriegen, zum Beispiel zum Abhören, müssen prüfen. Sie tun das nicht immer so, aber es gibt auch eine rechtliche Prüfung bei allen großen Providern, ob diese Anforderungen, die die kriegen, rechtmäßig sind. Aber was im Gesetz zu stehen soll, ist ja nicht, zumindest nach dem Entwurf, der diskutiert worden ist, der ja noch mal anders wird, aber es ist ja nicht, dass die Providere tun sollen, sondern es soll ja ein Richter vorbei sein. Und dem Richter wollte ich schon zumindest erstmal anders vertrauen als irgendeinem Justiziar in der Telco.
Der Richter sagt Quick Freeze ja oder nein? Oder der guckt sich die Daten an und sagt, welche davon verwendet werden?
Nein, also der sagt, ob die eingefrorene Daten sozusagen rechtmäßig sind.
Da bin ich das glaube ich nicht, Konstanze. Klassischerweise ist es so, dass eine Ermittlungsbehörde sagt, hier ist ein Vorfall, hier geht es um das Delikt. Wir wissen nicht genau, wer dahinter steckt, glauben aber, das ist hier schwere Kriminalität oder was auch immer. Und die Rahmenbedingungen passen, dass wir die Daten sehen. Dann sagt der Richter, stimmt, sehe ich auch so. Und dann kriegt aber die Strafverfolgungsbehörde die Daten. Da sagt jetzt nicht noch mal ein Richter und geht durch und guckt und dann googelt er die Personen, die da irgendwie rauskommen und sagt, oh, Moment mal, sind ja Leute, die investigativ arbeiten oder die irgendwie Therapeuten sind. Und das ist der Punkt, glaube ich.
Der Richter hat im Zweifel gar nicht die Zeit dafür. Gerade wenn ich mir anschaue, wie das mit dem Richtervollbehalt funktioniert. Das sind Sekunden im Zweifel. Das stimmt ja letztlich auch. Und da sind wir dann auch wieder bei der Kertwinde von eben der Frage, worauf ich mit dem Quick-Quiß hinaus wollte, mit der Zeit. In dem Moment, wo wir überlastete Behörden haben, die im Zweifel Wochen später auf Daten zugreifen wollen. Alleine dadurch entsteht ja schon der scheinbare Bedarf für die Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Wären die nicht dermaßen überlastet, wäre eine Quick-Quiß-Lösung für die problemlos ein tägliches Werkzeug, mit dem sie arbeiten können, mit dem sie sagen können, diese Daten hätten wir jetzt gerne bitte mal kurz festhalten. Dankeschön. Und da bräuchte man dann gar keine...
Und alle Alternativen haben genau diese Schnelligkeit im Fokus. Ja, wir haben... Also gestern... Es gab in Berlin eine große Konferenz, wo über diese unter anderem an alslose Massenspeicherung und die Attentiven gesprochen wurde. Und da geht es vor allen Dingen, also für mich jetzt, etwa noch um die Lock-in-Falle. Das ist auch so ein Mittel, das können wir jetzt sicherlich nicht im Detail erklären, aber wo man schnell möglichst jemand handeln will, um ihn in eine Falle zu locken. Also etwa wenn es um Beleidigung geht oder um Rechtsverletzungen und so. Also es gibt schon ein Team...
Du musst trotzdem kurz sagen, was ist seine Lock-in-Falle? Das hört sich an wie so ein Scam. Ich setze eine Webseite auf und versuche, dass sie sich da einlockt?
Nein, du versuchst keinen Scam aufzusetzen, sondern du versuchst jemanden festzunageln und zu warten, bis er sich das nächste Mal einlockt. Also ihm eine Falle zu stellen. Das ist ein bisschen komplexer das Konzept, aber...
Das gilt dann auch sozusagen für Plattformen und nicht nur für Telekommunikationsanbieter.
Ja, und vor allen Dingen ist es aber wiederum die Schnelligkeit. Da muss man in der Diskussion glaube ich hin, zu sagen, wir sind irgendwie in der Neuzeit, die müssen schnell reagieren, ansonsten droht uns diese anlasslose Massenspeicherung. Denn nur wenn die schnell agieren können, können die mit anderen Maßnahmen eine ordentliche Strafverfolgung machen.
Aber das ist schon ein ganz wichtiger Unterschied zu früher. Wir reden nicht mehr darüber, dass wir keine Überwachungsschnittstellen im Netz haben wollen. Es gab früher durchaus die Argumentation und die Position, dass man sagt, wir wollen keinerlei Vorratsdaten, speicherungsähnliche Konzepte haben, weil das immer ein Einfallstor ist für anlasslose Massenüberwachung.
Man kann auch die grundsätzliche Frage aufmachen, wollen wir Geheimdienste in unserem Staat tragen, die was Positives zu bei oder nicht. Also da kann man alles grundsätzlich diskutieren.
Ich glaube, was sich ja schon geändert hat, ist einfach diese Schnelligkeit, die jetzt auch einfach technisch viel mehr möglich geworden ist. Und was mir in meinem, in den Recherchen zur Pedikriminalität, was mir nicht einleuchtet, ist, es gibt so einen NECMEC-Verfahren. Das klingt kompliziert, ist aber eigentlich ganz einfach. Wenn du ein großes Social-Network z.B. in den USA bist, dann hast du die Pflicht, wenn du automatisiert siehst, da werden irgendwie Missbrauchsdarstellungen geteilt. Das wird automatisiert mit Haschen geprüft und dann wird auch die IP-Adresse gesammelt von den Leuten. Dann wird das in die Welt verteilt. Wenn klar ist, es ist eine IP-Adresse aus Deutschland, dann wird es in Deutschland geschickt. Das dauert mindestens mehrere Tage, bis das in Deutschland angekommen ist. Das verstehe ich schlichtweg nicht. Das ist ein großes Social-Network, das ist eine große Kinderschutzorganisation. Das ist so ein wichtiges Verfahren. Es vergehen immer viele, viele Tage, bis eine IP-Adresse vom Teilen selber da ist. Dass das nicht instantly da ist, okay. Aber dass das nach 10, 20 Minuten in einem automatisierten Verfahren hier ist. Ja, meiner Kenntnis nach ist es vor allen Dingen NECMEC. Diese Stelle, die das weiter verteilen muss. Aber bin ich jetzt nicht komplett sattelfest. Und auch, was man so hört, ist es jetzt auch nicht so, dass auf Seiten der deutschen Strafverfolgungsbehörden das dann alles automatisiert immer durchweg weiter verteilt wird. Das heißt, da gibt es schon, da bin ich voll bei, Konstanze, es gibt schon einige prozessuale Schritte, sage ich mal, die einfach deutlich optimiert werden könnten, um einfach massiv Zeit zu gewinnen.
Ich meine, seit dem Jahrzehnt. Das war das, was ich am Anfang meinte. Diese ganzen Versteifer auf die Vorwärtssattenspeicherung haben die Alternativen einfach mal ignoriert, ein ganzes Jahrzehnt. Und dann kommen sie mit den schlimmen Zahlen. Wo ich zu sagen, hättet ihr aber auch schon vor 10 Jahren, denn die Vorschläge sind teilweise schon so alt. Quick Freeze ist von, haltet euch fest, 2011. Sabine Leuthorst aus Schnarrenberger. Ey, weißt du, wie viel Zeit das ist? Die Lockenfalle ist jünger. Also die ist jetzt so, weiß ich nicht, drei Jahre alt oder so. Aber durch diese, oh Gott, wir wollen alles immer speichern, ist natürlich auch viel verloren gegangen, wenn man ausprobieren hätte können, wie es uns schneller machen können. Und ich finde es entfahrend, den Leuten zu unterstellen, die gegen die Vorratszeitenspeicherung sind. Sie hätten was prinzipiell gegen Überwachung. Ich finde es korrekt, dass man Leute, gegen die ein begründeter Verdacht besteht, überwacht. Da geht es nie darum, komplett Überwachung zu verhindern, sondern geht darum, dass wir die Bevölkerung nicht anlasslos speichern wollen. Ich finde, das ist ein politischer Argument. Ich weiß und so. Aber ich ziel dem Schumier überhaupt nicht an. Und ich wüsste auch nicht, dass in den ganzen Freiheitsstaaten Angst nehmen sollte, jemals darum ging, sich für irgendwelche Straftäter zu stellen. Sondern es ging immer darum, sich für die Bevölkerung einzusetzen, die einfach mal ein Recht hat, dass ihre Daten nicht festgehalten werden.
Das ist vor allem ein Symmetrie-Ding. Wir haben eine Handvoll Straftäter, wir haben eine Handvoll Strafverfolger. Das ist auf Augenhöhe. Wenn man von allen Bürgern alle Daten speichert und die einem kleinen Teil der Bevölkerung zugänglich macht, dann schafft man da eine Macht-Asymmetrie.
Na gut.
Das ist was ganz anderes als Strafverfolgung.
Jetzt ist ja die Frage... Ich hab gerade in meinem Kopf so ein bisschen in der Abflussfrage gefeilt. Ich glaube nicht. Im Sinne der Telefontele-Novella ist die Frage, wann treffen wir uns das nächste Mal wieder, um über die Vorratsdatenspeicherung zu sprechen?
Eine Weile nicht. Denn diese Plenum-Scheidung, die heute anders war, die vom 30. April, wird erst mal für eine ziemlich lange Zeit die letzte sein, dann steht nichts mehr an. Du weißt ja, es dauert immer sehr lange. Du konntest ja immer schon absehen, wann ungefähr die Urteile kommen. Erst mal wird zumindest vom EuGH nichts mehr kommen.
Aber wir treffen uns ja möglicherweise nicht nur, wenn das EuGH was enthörte, wir treffen uns ja vielleicht auch, wenn also...
Dann würde ich sagen, nächstes Jahr im Herbst oder Winter.
Wenn die AfD mit der CDU regiert?
Ich glaube, dann müsste man es nicht treffen, weil dann wäre die Sache wahrscheinlich durch. Wobei ich muss fairerweise sagen, ich weiß gar nicht, was die AfD zu dem Thema sagt. Ich vermute es mal, aber ich gucke mir jetzt deren Wahlprogramm nicht an. Ich finde es auch nicht gut, wenn wir solche Schreckenszenarien an jemanden machen. Aber ich glaube schon, dass in dieses Thema, ob wir wollen oder nicht, wird politisch Bewegung kommen nach der Bundestagswahl. Es sei denn, wir haben rot-grün.
Die müssen sich ja erst mal konstituieren.
Glaubt ihr alle nicht mehr, dass Quick Freeze in dieser Legislatur kommt?
Das kann sein, aber ich glaube nicht, dass...
Würden wir deswegen ein Chaosradio machen, ist die Frage.
Nein, ich glaube vor allen Dingen, dass Quick Freeze die Debatte nicht beenden wird. Weil jetzt schon Strafverfolgungsbehörden sagen, das ist nett, aber es reicht uns nicht. Das sagen die sehr klar, auch in Pressestatements. Und die Union wird das auch weiterhin pushen. Also das Thema wird bleiben.
Zumindest wäre ja auch die Zeit relativ knapp. Man muss ja auch mal über eine ernstzunehmende Evaluierung reden. Da müsste ja jemand mal draufgucken und sagen, wie gut funktioniert das, wie effizient ist das, wo muss man dann noch an Schrauben drehen. Und dafür wird die Zeit auch zu knapp sein, bis zur nächsten Regierung. Das ist natürlich auch auf jeden Fall so. Insofern würde ich mich da an den anschließen. Was denkst du, Nibler, wann werden wir uns das nächste Mal treffen?
Wenn man dich fragt.
Grobe Verabredungen in so ungefähr zwei Jahren, sag ich mal. Nächste Bundestagswahl plus warmlaufen, Gesetzesvorschläge machen.
Na ja, es könnte ja irgendwann noch was anderes passieren. Es könnte ja immer noch passieren, dass mal eine komplette Vorratssatz und Speicherungsatz eines Landes abhanden kommt. Das könnte ja noch passieren. Dann würde sich die Debatte, ich bin ja auch sehr gerne am Thema IT-Sicherheit, vielleicht auch noch mal wandeln.
Also falls ihr da Zugänge habt, der CCC, ist da, glaube ich, dankbarer Abnehmer im Zweifelsfall.
Ja, und ich glaube, was schon auch, glaube ich, wichtig wird, ist, dass wir auch noch stärker konstanter, das hat es ja gesagt, dass auch in Europa viele andere Länder das haben. Wir hantieren hier teilweise noch mit empirischen Daten, sozusagen, was hat die Vorratsdatenspeicherung damals gebracht. Die sind schon sehr, sehr alt, mittlerweile 15 Jahre oder mehr. Diese Erhebung, ich glaube persönlich, dass das noch sehr, sehr wertvoll wäre, eigentlich mal zu gucken in einem Land wie Italien. Die haben, glaube ich, auch eine relativ umfangreiche Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Wie sieht es da eigentlich aus, seitdem die das haben, mit der Kriminalitätsentwicklung in bestimmten Deliktsbereichen, wo man immer sagt, genau da würde es was bringen. Ich glaube, das wäre schon hilfreich, da noch Zeit rein zu investieren, dort mehr zu wissen.
Das wird auch gemacht. Zumindest ist es in Europa auch ein Thema, die Evaluierung einzuholen.
Mein Fazit, um den Bogen noch mal zu schließen, ich hatte am Anfang gesagt, dass das, an das ich mich erinnere damals, ist, dass es sehr lange der Fall war, dass Vorratsdaten gespeichert wurden, bis das ein Gericht einkassiert hat. Und mein Fazit ist, dass das, was ich damals mir als Handlungsanweisung daraus abgeleitet habe, kommuniziere, sodass keine Vorratsdaten anfallen.
Zumindest keine, die dich verraten.
Zumindest keine, die mich verraten.
Das ist auch noch eine technische Anleitung, wie das geht.
Gibt es bestimmt mehrere Chaosradio-Folgen, die wir verlinken können.
Man kann sich natürlich auf dem Splaster suchen, wo keine Metadaten anfallen. Man kann schon. Da wird es oft mit einer technischen Expertise verbunden.
Und das muss man ja aber auch...
Ich dachte, der Telekom reicht.
SpaceNet und Telekom müssen nicht vorwärts halten.
Na gut, das wäre dann wahrscheinlich tatsächlich aber nochmal eine eigene Sendung, um das nochmal ausführlich aufzudröseln. Wir würden an dieser Stelle uns glaube ich eher verabschieden. Vielen Dank. Daniel, Nibbler und Konz.
Und Markus.
Das war mal wieder... Dankeschön, Dankeschön. Das war mal wieder ein längeres Chaosradio. Mal gucken. Genau. Wisst ihr schon, was ihr in der nächsten Folge Dicke Bretter macht?
Tut mir leid. Wir haben da so ein NDA unterzeichnet. Aber es wird mega geil. Schaltet wieder ein.
So soll es sein. Bis dahin dürft ihr natürlich eine Sache nicht vergessen. Lasst euch nicht überwachen. Und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups.